that perhaps we already hot seat with
Joe like every single video
for seven and a half minutes because
specifically asking him questions about
feudal Japan what we didn't ask
oh answer
[Music]
well welcome back to a very special
OTR we are currently off the Record the
record and we got Queen oh colleagues
all right this is gonna be interesting
because as you guys know we have done so
many hot seat episodes with different
people and people on the crew our
regulars our hosts almost everybody
almost everybody almost everybody we
left one person out and that is Sir Joe
why did we but why but why
was it through just coincidence or was
it the fact that he just like talks
relentlessly always in every video
anyways
wait I was
just at the end no you're fine all right
yeah well um yeah so people some some
have to hypothesized
that perhaps we already hot seat with
Joe like every single video for seven
and a half minutes because specifically
asking him questions about feudal Japan
well no we didn't ask but he somehow
answered yeah yeah he brought it up but
like that's the other thing about Joe
which I think is tough about the hot
seat is is there a question that we
could like stump him with no is there
any question that we can get him like
hot and bothered that's a great question
Nick which is exactly why we're here
today how personal can we get
I actually feel like you might be this
the person of expertise in this area I
think I could wreck it because uh so I
think there's a Joe that we know
I think there's a shell
and then I think there's a real Joe the
soft Crab side and I think the delicious
after we crack it oh the meat here
[ __ ] sucking his legs out
he's so insecure and vulnerable oh the
meat
and I know uh Steve's really good with
like feeling and seeing where people are
at yeah I feel like you might know how
to get to the delicious crab meat look I
know my brother Joe I really he is a
brother to me I love Ollie I I swear to
God I love the JK crew you guys are my
family but yeah there is a part of Joe
that I feel like I could crack like a
[ __ ] crab
I'm in his seat
put the Hat on dude it has nothing to do
with this
say it again no honestly he's he's he's
more I mean he's more aware of himself
than people even know because he plays
into the [ __ ]
talking about
that was experts he does have a
character for JK his character that he
knows and he plays and he knows because
you can even be in mid video with
somebody half dude sometimes we'll have
somebody new here and then they're
making fun of Joe and then I look at Joe
and Joe Joe looks at me and I smile Joe
Smiles at me and like we I know that Joe
knows that he's putting a thing out
there that he's playing to and like we
both do that with each other but then
like it's like a weird like almost like
hey yeah I see you bro you're good so
like you can do your thing and so then
he just keeps playing he's a little Andy
Kaufman yeah very much so dude it's a
mind [ __ ] too because sometimes we'll do
JK and then we'll go to dinner and then
one time we went to Korean barbecue
Joe's is doing all the [ __ ] wild [ __ ]
you can think of and then at dinner you
forget that Joe's like a real person and
he goes so like how are things with you
and like Tiff man like
isn't that crazy I told you off yeah and
I'm like what the [ __ ] Joe you just in
my face or something I went to [ __ ]
Steve's house in Vegas for like New
Year's right and then Joe comes by as
well with him and stuff and then Joe's
like dressed properly he looks great
like it's weird it's his shirt is like
buttoned yeah you don't see his [ __ ]
bare chest he's got socks on and [ __ ]
I've never seen John and then he comes
in and he does regular [ __ ] human
[ __ ] like hey what's up guys shake your
hands or like you know when somebody
else is talking he's just standing there
and he's like listening I'm like what
the [ __ ] is this Anthony was only in my
house because of a mistaken invitation
I was like wait how did you get invited
this I was like I'm going to your place
for New Year's right he's like yeah dude
I got to sleep at 10 30.
he's not even dude so just to be clear
meaning but yeah Randy starts at 10.
yeah yeah no but no but uh so so how do
we how do we ask Joe questions on hot
seat that will get Joe off kilter
because that's the whole point of Hot
Seat we're trying to gotta figure out
hot seat questions for Joseph when he
gets here we're ready to go I want you
guys to be in on it too so that's tough
one of the most emotional times I've
ever seen Joe yeah is uh he's usually
like this shell that I don't know really
what's on the inside and
um when we were in Japan on a JK trip
that's when he found out his dog passed
away oh straight to the heart he got
killed by a coyote and
um I've never seen Joe like cry or even
emote in that way and he probably spent
like the next three days just like
devastated
and I was like holy [ __ ] that's crazy
there's like a like a person in there
did he witness the situation no it's I
think it's even worse because like you
know when you're away internationally
and it's like day here night there or
night here day there you just get a
phone call from the person that's
supposed to
um watch your dog uh this person likes
to delete footage as well but this
person let the dog get loose somehow and
then gets
so are you suggesting okay I'm just
trying to take what you're giving me
just so we can figure out how to see
questions are you suggesting something
like would you rather
have your dog back or like a present
father your whole life
oh [ __ ] I don't know are we too hot
already that's past the 11 minute Mark
11 and 17 seconds
okay that was all right that's not cold
enough yet that's past this start there
and work our way back okay but then from
that he was coming from that what was
Club was we've seen this giant growth of
Joe right it's like from there and like
just him I think feeling more
comfortable with everyone around him he
started to share that like up to that
point he never has ever even been
vulnerable with anybody yeah girlfriend
or anything and like brown which is his
dog's name because he's brown and Joe
would even Brown because it's because of
color he is not that smart it's just
like it was just because he was actually
the second option for names was dog
yeah because it's Joe he uh actually was
I think Brown helped open up his heart
oh and then helped him to start trust
and being vulnerable and open with
people again
so one of the things I actually love
about Joe one of the things that I
attached to Joe with early that made me
love Joe was his ability to to be your
friend like he could just be friends
with anybody yeah and and I'm not
kidding when I say this and maybe you
could correct me if I'm wrong because
you're the newest person here but Joe if
you're even new here he will go over
like he'll stumble over himself to help
you with something if you voice your
thing he's like I know a guy I know a
girl I know what trans I know a [ __ ]
whatever and we'll I'll get I'll get you
the help that you need and he'll give
you the recommend it in the room on the
day before you even barely asked about
it you said something for maybe five
seconds and he like over accepted it and
like tried to help you that's true it's
a fact it's just how he is but I love
that about the guy but but but something
along the way I think made it so that
Joe couldn't
protect Joe a little bit right so like
that's why yeah I gotta tell you guys
like a show chill Brown and then like
you know stuff relationship wise having
nothing to do with anyone in particular
but like guy just like went through some
stuff and then I think
you know one of my one of my favorite
things that he tells me privately that I
I will share publicly without his
permission
is that I I just told it I just told him
he broke up in my living room right with
his ex and like it was in my living room
bro I was there it was like wild but
like it was beautiful too because he was
so vulnerable and I've I've never seen
this guy try to stand up for someone who
didn't want to be with him anymore but
he was still trying to stand up
for this person so it's a closet simp
he's the same he was simply now he's a
sweetheart he was like you want me to
suck my own dick right now and then he
pulled his own pants down and started to
reach for it and then it was like sad
we're all like please don't suck your
own dick in my living room
no
meanwhile you're in the living room no
the guy was popcorn no he was real I I
can't do it all kidding is that he was
really just trying to just make all the
eyes dotted and all the t's crossed he
was really going for it and like that's
who Joe is right like if there's a one
percent chance he'll fight to the death
he will bro so
let me just see what I'm pulling from
what you're saying yeah yeah hot seat
questions you're saying something like
um if he had to hire and partner up with
one of his ex-girlfriends
that was recently a part of JK which one
would he be not recently but that was in
a part of JK's history which one would
he bring back and partner with
that's a good question oh yeah that's a
good question that's a really good
question that's a hot one yeah write
that one down write that one down can we
write these ones down because I don't
have [ __ ] to write you say that one more
time
so if he had to partner with get back
together rehire and partner with one of
his ex-girlfriends that came through JK
get back together and okay not get back
together because we love Hannah okay uh
partner partner with rehire and partner
with yeah one of the ex-girlfriends that
had worked for JK in the past and what
kind of business would it be yes that's
a good question and what are the two
roles they would play Then in that new
business too that's really good that's a
good question keep it for the questions
Joe loves that yeah we're not here to
answer it I have no idea where that's
gonna go but we all know that's kind of
fun and spicy for us yeah okay something
else that he told me right like um so I
you know I've been always very open
about me and Nikki like Nikki's my
[ __ ] one right and like for me I feel
like a lot of our friends
and it's not their fault it's just like
sometimes like people just get with
people and it's like maybe they're like
look relationships they're a little bit
miserable and I'm like no they're they
don't have to be bro yeah I'm just
telling you like because because of my
experience like yes I was in one of
those I know what that's like I was in a
couple of those I know what that's like
but like no they don't have to be
miserable and I think that he didn't
quite believe me until he got with
Hannah and then he just like he pulled
me aside recently and he and again we
can edit this out if like I don't want
to speak out of turn because he's told
me that but he was like dude I'm so glad
that I listened to you on that because I
was so I was open for it with Hannah and
like we don't fight like we well they do
fight obviously but they don't fight I
think there's a little bit Yeah
bickering but like it's but like it's
it's progress right if you like like you
know the the metaphor of like you know
stool sharp and steel it's it's like you
know you can kind of make each other
stronger especially in the initial when
you're just like butting heads a little
bit but then if you're productive with
it you can really make it into a
relationship where you don't fight and
like I'm telling you I am obsessed with
Nikki everyone knows I [ __ ] love my
wife but that's only because we fought
so much in the beginning we had to
[ __ ] sharpen each other
and then it got easy
so what you're saying this is
inspirational instead of pulling these
questions out you're good it's a good
conversation maybe something like what's
the number one way that Hannah's made
you a better person that's really good
that's really good flyer that's right
iron sharpens iron brother
we're not friends right now but right
now it's about Joe you guys make a good
team hey we're putting the swords down
for the video hey [ __ ] off hey [ __ ] up
Nick you know what'd be funny is if
right when we started we go all right
it's the zero zero zero Mark well we
like to turn up the heat a little bit
we're like in the cold question what's
the number one thing that Hannah made
you Betty for
Char his ass out of the back for this
one but it's gonna shut the [ __ ] up get
the [ __ ] out of here
no but he look the guy like I feel like
everyone deserves happiness and I think
that Joe like really just needed to to
actually have someone who could handle
like his love language because I Believe
In Love Languages I believe in matching
people who like like so for me and Nikki
it's quality time like we don't give a
[ __ ] about gifts we've never given like
a [ __ ] less about gifts so it's like
it's it's just about quality time for us
it's like hanging out with each other
and so like that's our big thing for Joe
it's salad tossing for Joe it's getting
his [ __ ] eat now by by women or men
or whoever
yeah Sam's twink versatiles dictators or
whatever
so write that down
dude actually that's kind of like a sick
open-ended question just being like Joe
what's your love language oh yeah I
think I know from his mouth you know it
could be like what do you think your
love languages have them answer it and
then go what do you think Hannah thinks
your love language is that's good do you
he's gonna be like can't compute but
then we gotta ask it separately we gotta
ask it separately
yeah because I think you're significant
other usually has a better view of who
you are than even yourself that's true
huh but Joe gotta say being completely
honest I love to roast people you guys
all know that but that's my love
language too but because that's how I
perceive and give love because I grew up
in such a big family so there's almost
no attention so you you get attention
Through Fire yeah but but Joe Joe is
honestly like maybe the nicest guy I
think I know almost too nice like he
really is like say that's a dude that he
[ __ ] up back in the day huh oh yeah
nope those guys had it coming dude I'm
telling you it doesn't matter who the
[ __ ] you are he'll he'll talk [ __ ] and
stuff like that yeah and it's funny and
I know how that is because I have
porcupines myself but he really will
help anybody he will I got a question
yeah so clean you uh maybe have known
him the least in a sense like based off
of your impressions what's something
that you're curious about asking him
that's a good question feel free to cut
as deep as you want just genuine
um well piggyback off of Steve I I do
believe that Joe is such a kind generous
person because I think it's maybe the
first or second time that I was on
um I hanged back for a little bit and we
talked for like an hour and a half
um and it was and we got into like a
deep conversation I was like about the
weather like oh what do you do
um so I agree with that so I guess my
question would be to him would be
do you think you receive the same
treatment that you give out oh that's
good Jesus put that down that's really
awesome you kind of gotta like warm up
too in good conversation right yeah
right that's a nice like after the 12
minute more attack yeah maybe like 15.
oh [ __ ] we're getting spicy we shouldn't
make it a [ __ ] 30 minute video I
think we might have to for uh for a Joe
one you know because I feel wasn't yours
pretty long
um I was hoping I was gonna end soon
about the business boss yeah
quick fire Quest
too long in there uh most recent porn
you busted enough oh that's good oh yeah
sometimes you need some shallow [ __ ] you
know yeah that's that's early I hope
it's not boring it might be I hope you
watch some weird [ __ ] well you know he
did give us a gem about the Korean uh
hentai ones remember yeah
come to the ceiling yeah that one that's
the one that's what I want to hear about
also just to like tap into you know Joe
Mama's side if he could [ __ ] beat
anyone's ass in the world right now who
would it be anyone's Ingress is one of
his love languages
foreign
and then
um we'll wait for the video because I'm
not going to say what but Hey Joe can I
just read like your most recent text to
careful boys chat
yes whatever it is
anything yeah whatever it is also what
was the last movie that you watched
twice
all the time all the time see an answer
for that it is a very good question
these are good this is the first time
we've actually [ __ ] prepped yeah I
know this actually does make for a
better yeah this is gonna work well the
best thing is everyone's gonna be in on
it they're going to be hot they're going
to know what the questions are you think
Joe's gonna watch this video before it
airs oh she has a choice like literally
nobody knows what the [ __ ] happens with
uploads yeah I think because of our
[ __ ] up uploading schedule we won't
even know when this comes out after yeah
and it's gonna come out this will come
out the Tuesday after the joke video
coming can might just delete this
he's not even here today
such a big doofy
it hurts her yeah oh my God you know
it's a JK like that's not just a new
view hey what that's not an oofie and
oofy would be like almost did it doofy
would be doing it do dude come on bro so
everybody everybody watching put it in
the comments if there's a question you
think is hot enough for Joe's hot seat
that we're taking extra care preparing
yeah uh let us know what you think and
something that you want to know from Joe
and uh and don't hold back
please don't yeah but if you have
questions about Tiff and Josh like go
[ __ ] yourself
[Laughter]
thank you
foreign